ils sont nombreux mais ils sont toujours
aussi déterminés léger les jaunes ont
joué au chat et à la souris avec les
forces de l'ordre
délogés des ronds points comme ce matin
à saint marcel ils ont investi d'autres
aux axes stratégiques pour continuer à
ralentir la circulation et exprimer leur
ras-le-bol
philippe à participer aux opérations de
blocage tout le week-end il était encore
là aujourd'hui l'état d'esprit
aujourd'hui
en gros il y en a marre il y en a ce
matin ce matin j'ai même craquer chez
moi là on est on en gros on est sur les
nerfs mais on lâchera pas ce lundi les
routiers ont participé à leur façon au
mouvement
ils n'ont pas bloqué la route avec leur
camion les stationner souvent plusieurs
minutes au point de blocage pour
apporter leur soutien au gilet jaune
on est obligé de soutenir on est tous
dans la même galère vous savez moi je
suis entièrement d'accord et que vous
savez quand vous allez à la pompe à
essence et que vous voyez que c'est plus
en plus cher je crois qu'on est tous
touchés
je soutiens oui parce qu'on a un peu
surtaxé quand même donc j'aurai bien
bosser quand même je croyais être une
petite société donc c'est que ça nous
rende hommage un petit peu du côté des
automobilistes si certains commencent à
trouver le temps long
la plupart gilet jaune sur le pare-brise
soutiennent le mouvement ou d'un moment
on n'arrête pas de nous prendre à gauche
à droite et au bout d'un moment faut
dire stop
donc voilà ce week-end oui j'étais
manifesté samedi et là je vais sûrement
les rejoindre les manifestants qui
auront points je rentre du travail
c'est ça oui il faut qu'il continue
comme ça quoi c'est bien voilà c'est
compliqué à gérer au quotidien pour nous
quand on est sur la route mais il faut
qu'ils tiennent bon j'ai l'impression
que ça fait plus chier nous qu'autre
chose mais que l'état moi ça m'embête là
ça fait une heure que dans la voiture et
que j'attends donc clairement ça
m'énervait
ce soir le mouvement des gis les jeunes
ne s'est pas affaiblie en saône et loire
au contraire actifs retraités jeunes ou
non ils sont tous déterminés à ce que
leur colère soit entendu